[Music]
Amy Schumer's audience walks out after
she bashes at Donald Trump it's very
surreal the comedian was performing in
Tampa when things got political so tell
me why husband then Amy trashed
Donald explained why she's voting for
Hillary Clinton and talked about sexual
assault and gun control all in all it
lasted about 10 minutes
dozens of people exited at some even
booed Amy one audience member tells et
it went on longer than it should have
especially since she was only out there
for a little over an hour
another eye witness says many in
attendance were talking about being
uncomfortable with all the political
talk after the show
this comes after Amy trashed Tampa and
her best-selling book the girl with the
lower back tattoo what better way to
open the hook in it she called the city
horrendous and said the people of Tampa
can't read et reached out to Amy for
comment about the show and she told us
this quote we have always depended on
comedians to make us laugh and tell the
truth I am proud to continue that
tradition
you
[Music]